so too sweet Josh today we are going to
find out which pre-made Oh is the best I
love chocolate chip cookies me too I
love chocolate chip papers especially if
they got sprinkles love sprinkles
confetti sprinkles with chocolate chip
cookies inside it's a thing chocolate
chip cookies with Oreos baked in the
center look there's a thing as well and
those are super Bob you've lived so many
lives yes
[Music]
this is already a step I don't normally
get to because like to get to this step
you have to actually put it in the oven
on first look here I would say this
looks like it's gonna be moist this
one's a really thin super thin so we've
got the thin going on a lot of chocolate
chips of them yeah there's a lot there's
a good it's pretty crumbly I would say
but it is sticking together okay but it
is like it will fall apart in your hands
[Laughter]
yeah I'm very good there's like simple
but really good not my favorite
I like that I like the size and so Q I
like that yeah these are a little dainty
okay these are a little fellas first up
I know that a lot of James Tollhouse
does like the square shape for the dough
that's how much I know about it you know
what I'm just gonna do a little tear
pull this makes me think of they're like
break off square ones just because of
the size like maybe that's the
orientation better I like it better but
I'm with it these are a little less
flavorful I think than the first one
yeah the other ones I would say still
might might be my top choice so far but
these are definitely good you know I
wouldn't say no tool doesn't blow my
mind
not really it's very good I like it I
like a lot
[Music]
look at yes very for you look at this
big boy Wow
love it when you call me big papa if you
told me these came from like some little
boutique Bistro and might be a $7 cookie
right here this is like solid like this
looks like itll like it's the older Big
Brother cookie and it's gold
there is no crumble happening right now
it is yeah very solid
probably like a Miss Fields cookie ears
oh that's a good bet there's just like
really dense oh no I don't like that I
hate this one I'll eat the whole thing
I'm not gonna eat I don't know if I like
it much it has almost kind of like a
weird aftertaste if I was walking the
street alone I would have hit like a
mugger with this the cookies is more
what I'm used to you know I just go for
that kind of thing whatever cookie that
one yeah you know big soft and you think
it's your top one right now um out of
the cookies that we've had today yes no
the best cookie that I've even like in
your life
[Music]
looks kind of green I'm gonna be real
surprised if this is the best flavor cuz
you know no shape to this cookie
whichever one he is but he just looks
real tired there's like a texture there
is like texture happening on this cookie
this this looks like a dog treat first
thank you it does it has a good break
and it is very gooey looking in the
center so let's check that out I don't
like that at all I would rather have the
last one than this one no for us it's
like some I try to give me a healthy
cookie I'm actually gonna swerve a
little and say this is my second
favorite pace wise but it is easily
bottom of the pack presentation-wise
yeah I'm just not into this one yeah
it's too crumbly it feels like it almost
feels like it doesn't have butter yeah I
don't like this one not a fan yeah no no
no no no thank you
my favorite is this second one the one
that almost looked like it kind of had a
square shape that's my favorite one but
that one ones it for the third one yeah
I get there one number two I think I
would say number one number one is my
favorite with a second-place finish for
the last one I think I said I saved the
second one I agree the second one is the
most classical told me one second with
this whole house it is right Wow
okay little bit your favorite pillsbury
okay
okay that makes sense of last one Wow
okay there you go
get movin I didn't want to be really
mean to gluten-free I love you but I
just wasn't expecting you to come to my
party so basically we have we have very
basic tastes that rings about how I
would have thought it was gonna go down
Toll House just like tried-and-true
tastes like a late-night regret I love
it
[Music]